Mind your decisions I'm Presh Talwalkar
In a square with a side length of one
Construct two quarter circles and then inscribe a circle between the quarter circles
The challenge is to solve for the circles radius. I think Pradeep Hebbar for the suggestion
Pause the video. If you'd like to give this problem a try and when you're ready keep watching to learn how to solve this problem
We'll get started by drawing lines between the corner of the square and the tangent point on the inscribed circle
The first thing we'll do is we'll prove that this intersection point all is the center of the circle
We'll get started by considering one quarter circle
consider the tangent point and the tangent line
The perpendicular to this tangent line will pass through the center of the quarter circle
Point A and it will pass through the center of the inscribed circle
However, we don't know the exact location of O
Now, let's consider the other quarter circle. We'll do a similar construction
We have the tangent line and then the perpendicular to the tangent line
This will pass through the center of the quarter circle
which is the corner of the square and then it will also pass through the centre of the inscribed circle O .
If we put these observations together
the intersection point of these two lines
Must contain the center O and therefore this is the center of the inscribed circle
Now let's focus on this quarter circle
The square has a side length of one which means the radius of this quarter circle is equal to one
Suppose the inscribed circle has a radius equal to R. This means the distance between the two centers is 1 minus R
We then drop a perpendicular
which will be a radius of the inscribed circle and this will bisect the side of the square into two lengths of 0.5
We thus have the following right triangle and we can use the Gougu theorem
0.5 squared plus R squared is equal to the quantity 1 minus R squared
Well, then do some simplifying algebra the R squares cancel out and then we can routinely solve for R
We carefully calculate that R is equal to
0.375 and that's equal to 3 over 8
Think this is a fun little problem
Thanks for making mind your decisions one of the best channels on YouTube as always. Thanks for watching and thanks for your support